ده رئيس التونسي وقيس سعيد القوات
العسكريه والامنيه والقضاء للتصدي لمن
وصفهم بالمتامرين على الدوله والاستجابه
لما وصفه بمطلب تطويل البلاد
وجزمت جبهه الخلاص المعارضه بين سعيد وصل
الى مازق كبير جعله يتخبط ويخلط بين
المهام في موقف كزمنا مع تمديد اتحاد
الشغل بتوقف احد بقلبه داعيا للتعبئه
دفاعا عن الحريه والحق في الادراك
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان ذلك خبر حلقتنا ولانا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما الحجج التي ساقتها
رئاسه التونسيه في قرارها تمديد حاله
الطوارئ في البلاد وهي المره الاولى التي
تمدت فيها لمده عام كامل
ودعوتها الامن والجيش والقضاء لتطهير
البلاد وتفعيل المحاسبه وكيف نفهم تصيد
الراهنه بينها وبين اتحاد الشغل ومن هم
الموتى امرون على الدوله واعداء الوطن
خارج المساءله الذين وصفه سعيد بهذا الوصف
في اكثر من مناسبه وما ترجمه هذه القوات
المسلحه والقضاه على التصدي لهم في الوقت
الذي تتهم فيه تتهموا في المعارضه بتوظيف
هذه الاجهزه لتصفيه خصومه السياسيين وما
هي فرصه حل حاله الازمه السياسيه في
البلاد واستجابه مختلفه برافو لدعوات
للحوار والتي كان اخرها دعوه اماميه لحوار
مفتوحا وشامل عقب الاقبال الضعيفه للتصويت
في الجوله الثانيه من الانتخابات
البرلمانيه
[موسيقى]
من قليله من افصح صناديق الاقتراع في
الانتخابات التشريعيه عن الضعف نسبه
للمشاركه الشهيدها التاريخ السياسي الحديث
لتونس
ظهر الرئيس قيس سعيد في كلمه اختار ان
يطلقها من ثقنه رئيسيه للحرس الوطني
وبحضور قاده الامنينا ماردينا اعتبرتها
المعارضه اصرارا من الرئيس التونسي على
القفزي فوق الرساله التي كشفها العزوف
الكبير عن التصويت وجر لساحه السياسيه الى
مربع الانميا قضائيا ينكر فيه سعيد بخصونه
وفقه قوانين ومراسينا خاضها على المقاس
دعى اخرها الى تمديد حاله الطوارئ عاما
كاملا خلافا للمعمول به سابقا
اقصر منها بكثيره
رئيسه جبهه الخلاص الوطني في تونس احمد
نجيب الشابي اتهم الرئيس السعيد بتوظيف
القضاء العسكري للانتقام من خصومه على نحو
يضر بحياد الجيش ما خصصه الرئيس السعيد من
حيز للعمل النقابي وما اعاقب ذلك من
اعتقال مسؤول النقابي دفعت احدى الشغل الى
عقد اجتماع طارئ لمكتبه التنفيذي واصدار
بيان عبر فيه عن تنديره بعمليه الايقاف
بوصفها ضربا للعمل النقابي وحقوقهم واشار
البيان الى ان عمليه الايقاف جرت مباشره
بعد كلمه رئيس الجمهوريه داعيا مختلف
الهياكل النقابيه في البلاد الى التعبئه
والاستعداد لدفاع عن الحق النقابي وحق
الاضراب والحريات العامه والفرديه
هذا وكان الرئيس قيس سعيد سعيد قد دعى
القوات المسلحه والامنيه والقضاه الى
التصدي لمن اعتبرهم متامرين على الدوله
تابع جانبا من هذه الكلمه
اليوم وانتم تقودون سلكا من بين اهم
الاسباب
القواتره المسلحه الامنيه
وقواتنا المسلحه العسكريه التي قامت بدورا
تاريخيا ايضا في تامين الانتخابات عليكم
وعلى القضاه الشرفاء
ان يقوموا بدورهم
كاملا
حتى
يتم التصدي
لمن تامروا على الدوله
للسنوات الماضيه
وما سالوا الى حد هذه الساعه
يتامرون على الدوله
وعلى الشعب
[موسيقى]
ليه مناقشه هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من
تونس جوهر بن مبارك القيادي في جبهه
الخلاص الوطني ومن سوسه ينضم الينا قيصر
الصياحه المحامي والباحث في القانون اهلا
بكما استاذ سياح واستاذ قيصر ابدا معك
استاذ قيصر طبعا استمعنا الى الكلمه كلمه
ناريه كالعاده بعد انتخابات طبعا نتائجها
كانت او المشاركه الانتخابيه كانت فيها
هزيله جدا يعني نسمع في هذه الكلمه
مصطلحات من قبيل تطهير محاسبه امن قضاء
وغير ذلك
وعيد وتهديد في اتجاهات شملت حتى العمل
النقابي في اي سياق يمكن ان نفهم هذه
الكلمه
شكرا مساء الخير اولا الانتخابات
التشريعيه وضعت اوزارها واسجل السيجاره
نهائيا ولو ان هناك عزوفا انتخابيه واضحا
لان هذا العزوف الانتخابي هو عزوف اي قاضي
للطيف السياسي الذي كان يحكم البرلمان في
الفتره الفارته والذي راينا كما راينا من
احداثهم فوضى وصلت الى حد الدماء داخل
مجلس النواب وبالتالي فان هذا العزوف
وعزوف طبيعي وحدث في الجزائر وحدث في
العراق وفي فرنسا
لم تحدث في اي بلد من دول العالم نتحدث عن
تقريبا 90% من الناس قاطعوا او يعني لم
يشاركوا في هذه الانتخابات وهذا شيء غير
مسبوق في تاريخ تونس وفي دول كثيره في
العالم
نحن قلنا ان هذا هو هذا هذا هذه النسبه
نسبه ضعيفه لكنها تعكس العزوف العقاب
رئيس الجمهوريه التونسيه بدليل ان رئيس
الدوله قبل خمسه اشهر او سته اشهر من هذا
التاريخ خرج ثلاث ملايين ساكن
في الانتخابات
كلمه الرئيس قيصر سعيد جاءت في سياقا
تاريخي مفصلي لان الانتخابات التشريعيه
وقلت هذا منذ اسبوعين تقريبا ان الرئيس
يمرع القصوى ولا رجوع الى الوراء خاصه انه
يريد تركيز السلطه التشريعيه التمثيليه
للشعب التونسي وهو يحصل على المشروعيه في
هذا الشكل من خلال انتخابه كرئيس ومن خلال
تمثيليه اخرى ثانيه
تؤسس لمقاومات سلطتين اساسيتين في تونس
متلازمتين من حيث الفحوى ومن حيث العمل
والنمط السياسي وبالتالي الرئيس يعتبر ان
المشروعيه انتهت الان والشرعيه انتهت
بوجود مجلس تشريعي تاسيسي رسمي في قاره
طريق جديده سترها الرئيس وحدد مقوماتها
وحدد عناصرها وهو يمر الان الى تطبيق
القانون بسرعه القصوى يعني دوله وصلت الى
مرحله فوضى لا مثيل لها
خلينا ننتقل الى السيد جوهر يعني الى
الامام سر لا رجوع الى الوراء كما يقول
القيس الاستاذ قيصر
المحاسبه والتطهير تطهير البلاد من
المتامرين ومن الخونه يعني هذا اكيد مطلب
لا يتناطق فيها عن ذلك ما يقال ما المشكله
في هذا الامر اذا بنسبه لكم
لا يعني قيس سعيد في الحقيقه هو يواصل في
خطاب
الجزء الثاني من خطاب الانكار بعد خطاب
خطاب به الاول من القصبه من رئاسه الحكومه
عندما قال بان الشعب التونسي لم يذهب الى
صناديق الاقتراع لانه كاره همم
للبرلمان ثم بعد ذلك بعد الليله يخرج
ويقول بان همم الشعب التونسي لم يذهب الى
صناديق الاقتراع لانه ينتظر المحاسبه هي
محاوله لتبرير وفهم الفشل الذريع الفشل
غير المسبوق الفشل التاريخي الفشل العالمي
للانتخابات التي همم اجريت في صوتها الاول
لانه كان يطلب شوطا ثانيا
واعطاه الشعب التونسي درسا ثانيا في الشوط
الثاني الذي طلبه طبعا نفهم حاله الارباك
التي همم يكون عليها قيس سعيد وكل منظومته
وكل انصاره وكل المطبلين له هم في حاله
ايرباق وحاله انكار مرضيه همم يحاولون
الهروب من الواقع الداهم عليهم بان الشعب
التونسي لفظ منظومه 25 جويريه بان الشعب
التونسي ليس منخرطا في منظومه 25 جويليه
وانه لم يشارك ابدا في اي محطه من محطات
الانقلاب خريطه الطريق التي قام بها قيس
سعيد واعلن عنها من اربع خطوات منيت همم
الاربع خطوات بالفشل فشل الاستشاره
الالكترونيه فشل الحوار المزعوم فشل
الاستفتاء الدستوري وكذلك الفشل الانتخابي
همم العمليه كاملا هي عمليه فاشله المشكله
الان ان هذه السلطه متشنجه الان متشنجه
ومتوتره ويمكن ان همم ان تستعمل وتوظف
اجهزه الدوله والاجهزه الصلبه للدوله من
اجل ان تنتقم المعارضيها وتحمل وتبحث في
المعارضها عن كبش فداء يمكن ان تحمله
مسؤوليه هذا الاخطاء
تحمل احد معارضيها ان يكون كلب هذه النقطه
نعم فتوقف عند هذه النقطه ااه استاذ قيصر
الخطاب غدا مباشره الى تحرك فعلي على
الارض يتمثل في القبض على قيادي نقاب وهو
بالمناسبه ما تفعل معه اتحاد الشغل على
اعلى مستوى مباشره كيف نقرا ذلك هو ضجيج
ربما يعني يريد ان يحدث ضجيجا من اجل
التغطيه على الفشل الانتخابي
لا لا ليس صحيح لا لا لا ضجيج ولا ولا شيء
المساله واضحه وضوح الشمس يعني اولا يجب
ان نتفق على شيء مهم جدا في علم السياسه
وبالرغماتيه الواقعيه دون حياد ان ال ال
الوضع الذي الت اليه تونس الان تسببت فيه
اطياف كثيره
واقتصادي وتدخل رئيس الدوله في الوقت
الحاسم اعتبر ذلك لاصلاح الامور ولو ان
هناك بعض الطبات وبعض الالهينات ثانيا
المعارضه غريب بامر المعارضه والتفسير
الذي ينتقد قصص سعيد رئيس الدوله لا لا لا
اعرف لماذا الى الان يمر الى الوراء ولا
يريد اصلاح له وضعيه او الاعتراف بالخطا
او اصلاح مشاكل السياسيه على الاقل وهو
الذي يمر بحاله شبه رئيس دينيه الان حرب
الامعاء الخاويه
اريد ان اؤكد على نقطه هامه انا ما سالت
ايقاف همم النقابي اليوم في بهذا الشكل
بعد تصريحات الرئيس جاءت اولا في سياق ان
109 ملف اضاءه لقيادات امنيه ولا قضيه
قبره في البلاد معناها يعني يا شخصيه
سياسيه محاله على القضايا من الجرائم
خطيره جدا البعض منه يتعلق بالماسات بامن
الدوله الداخلي والبعض منها الان لدى الان
تقول باليوم
فرنسا والان الدوله تقوم بتطبيق القانون
ولا مجاله
بطريقه سياره باتجاه تونس العاصمه وكانت
موافق
هل هي موثقه بالاثباتات والادله اذا كان
حتى العمليات الاغتيال التي يقول انه تعرض
لها لم يقدم ايه ادله عليها
الرئيس غير محمول على تقديم ادله هذا رئيس
جمهوريه التونسيه
ادلبي بعض الملفات وليس مطالبا على الشاشه
كل يوم وهو يقبل القسدس
ككل البشر عندما يوجه اتهامات عندما يواجه
اتهامات الى اطراف سياسيه والى خصوص
سياسيين او خصوم نقابيين عليه ان يقدم
الادله على ما يدعي ولكن
اعتقد ان قيس سعيد دابا على هذه العاده في
توجيه الاتهامات جذافا انه مشكل كما يقول
سيدتي هو اننا الان امام هذا التوتر
السياسي والاخفاق السياسي الكبير وتوتر
السلطه القائمه وتشنجها ودخلها في حاله من
الهستيريا الجماعيه اعتقد ان الخوف الان
هو ان همم ان يتجرع على مجزره حقوقيه بدات
ما لم يخرها همم
توظيف القضاء وتوظيف همم المؤسسات الصلبه
للدوله وكان حديثه
اسرار
الرئيس على المعالج الامنيه والمعالجه كما
تقول الصلبه والخشنه ما الهدف من ذلك
الهدف واضح هو انه فاقد لزمام المبادره
السياسيه وغير قادر ان يخرج من المخنق
الذي ترد فيه وكل سلطه سلطه مغتصبه سلطه
غير شرعيه عندما تصل الى مثل هذه المخانق
فانها تتصرف بشكل متشنج وشكل عنيف همم هذا
ما قلناها
استاذ قيصر
غريب ربما لدى كثيرين يعني سياسه
الاستعداد التي ينتجها رئيس قيس سعيد تجاه
المعارضه ولكن مش فقط المعارضه حتى احبابه
طبعا احبابه بين قوسين الذين لم ينتقدوا
ما فعله او لم يسموه على الاقل من خلال
مسار 25 يوليو اتحاد الشغل مثلا لم يسمي
ما حدث بانه قلاب رغم ذلك يتعرض لما يتعرض
له من الرئيس
سعيد كيف نفهم ذلك
نفهم ذلك واضح نعم نفهم ذلك لان هناك ايضا
سبعه اطياف مكونات سياسيه من احزاب كثيره
في تونس منها حركه الشعب وتيار الشعبي
وحزب البعث الى اخره وكثير من الاحزاب
التي تساند الى الان الرئيس الدوله قيس
سعيد ثم ان المنظمه الشغليه وهي منظمه
الاكبر في البلاد الى جانب الاتحاد
الصناعه والتجاره التونسي اصرحت عديد
المرات انها لا تقبل مطلقا مصطلح الانقلاب
وانها ضمن مسار 25 جويليه لكن مع تعديل
اوتاره في بعض الجزئيات
بخصوص رئيس قيس سعيد فهو لا يتوجه الى
معاناه الاتحاد الشغل بدليل ان رئيس سعيد
اتفق عديد المرات بثلاثه مناسبات ديسمبر
2020 ماسمي بمحاوله ايجاد مخرج في حوار
الخروج من الازمه ثم في سنه 21 وسنه 22 في
شهر يونيو 22
ما سمي في تلك اللحظه عند خروج السيد
الطبوبي من القسم
ب- بمبادره لا بمبادره المرور الى الحوار
ليس به بالفعل ورد الفعل اذا الرئيس قام
بعده محطات
نعم استمعت الى الاستاذ جوهر يقول لك انه
هذا الرئيس يسر على استعمال ادوات صلبه
ادوات خشنه معالجه امنيه معالجه قضائي
يعني حتى القضائيه عليها تحفظ الان ان
يعني نريد ان نفهم ويفهم على المشاهد كيف
لرئيس مدني يؤمن بالديمقراطيه ان يعين
عسكريا ما زال على راسي وظيفته ومنصبه
العسكريه وظيفه في منصب مدني كوزير
للفلاحه
يا سيدتي يجب ان اتعرف لا تتعارض مع
الحقوق الحقوق مضمونه في تونس الان ولا
ولا ادري لماذا
على راس مهام العسكريه تعيين وكوازير
للفلاحه
لما يكون في قاموس
السياسيه في العالم كله
انه عندما يستقيل من منصبه العسكري يعين
في منصبه السياسيه بعد تقاعده او استقالته
وليس وهو على راس عمله كعسكري يعين كوزير
وزير فلاح
انا اؤكد لك انا هذا في قاموس وابجديه علم
السياسه ان الوزراء الذين يحتلون مناصب
كما حدث تتمكن من وزاره الصحه عسكري ايضا
منذ التقريب سته اشهر في تونس لا يكون
بهذه الطريقه الرجل خرج من مهامه وعين
بمهام سياسيه
هل ترى سيد جوهر ترى ذلك طبيعيا
لا لا هي في الحقيقه خطاباته من السكنات
العسكريه وبدايه حشر العسكريين
والجيش في الحياه السياسيه هي امر منتظر
وطبيعي لسلطه الانقلاب باعتبار نقيس سعيد
ليس له اي مرتكز
كدعيم لسلطته هو لا يملك حزبا سياسيا لا
يملك اداه الاداره ليس ابن الاداره ليس
ابنه
المؤسسه العسكريه هو تقريبا منبت ومنقطع
تماما وبالتالي لا يرتكز على شيء الان
وخاصه بعد انهيار شعبيته الا على هذه
المؤسسات الصلبه هي رساله في اتجاه
التونسيين والتونسيات ليقول انه حتى وان
لم تاتوا الى صناديق الاختراع حتى وان لم
تسندوني في العمليه السياسيه فاني مستند
الى القوى الصلبه وفي ذلك تهديد مبطن ايضا
لخصومه ولكن من جهه اخرى ايضا قيس سعيد
عينه شخصا وزيرا على على راس وزاره
التربيه وفي ذلك ايضا رساله رساله
للاتحاد الشغل باعتبار ان من عينه هو من
اكبر معارضي القياده الحاليه للاتحاد هو
نقابي ومن معارضي القياده الحاليه للاتحاد
وفي ذلك ايضا رساله تصعيديه تجاه الاتحاد
رافقت الرساله التي ارسلت البارحه بالقاء
القبض بعمليه امنيه كبيره على احد
القياديين
النقابيين اعتقد ان هذا قيس يريد ان يوصل
رسائل
رده فعل ان التونسيين حتى وان كانوا غير
مساندين للمسار السياسي فانه يستند على
المؤسسه العسكريه وماضي قدما في
الى اين استاذ قيصر ماضي قدما نحو كما
يقال بالعميه رايح نحو الحيط ولا الى يعني
هناك دعوات
من منظمات دوليه من الامم المتحده
للاحتكام الى الى العقل والى الحوار هناك
دعوات للحوار هل تعتقد ان الرئيس قيس سعيد
سيستجيب لنداءات الحوار وعلى راسها نداء
الامم المتحده
اولا الرئيس الرئيس سعيد
هيبه الدوله التي طالما نادى بها ايضا
الرحله السيد الباجي قائد الزبزي والدوله
كانت تنهار منذ سنه تقريبا 2015 في
مؤسساتها ومقاوماتها وصلنا الى 32,000
اضراب يعني رقم رهيب في العالم وتوقفت
اجهزه الدوله وبلغنا 110 الف مليار ديون و
130 بالمئه عام ثانيا بخصوص مساله ايقاف
هذا النقاب او القيادي بجماعه النقل
بالامس كان على اثر ايقاف العمل وتعطيه
الحريه الخدمه بطرقات السياره بتونس لماذا
المعارضه تنكر كل هذا لماذا تهرب الى
الوراء لماذا تنصدم بالجدار لماذا لا تريد
ان تقول
الى الى ماذا
خلينا نقول كلامك هذا الى جوهره نختم في
اقل من دقيقه بالاستاذ جوهر يعني يعني
تاخذون كما قال بس الى الى الاصطدام
بالجدار الى اين تذهب تونس في المرحله
المقبله
يعني هذا حديث غير عقلاني الذي يقود الان
تونس ويمتلك كل السلطات وكل المقود بين
يديه والذي يحملها الى الازمه ولم
تنهر قيمه الدوله وهيبه الدوله ودوله
القانون في تاريخ البلاد لم تشهد تونس هذه
المرحله
منذ مئات السنين لم تنهر الدوله التونسيه
بهذه الطريقه همم من يملك السلطه الان هو
قيس سعيد من يقود العمليه هو قيس سعيد
ومنذ عام ونصف اخفق هذا الرجل في تحقيق اي
تقدم وان كان ميكروسكيا في اي ملف من
الملفات سواء كانت الاقتصاديه او
الاجتماعيه او السياسيه او البيئيه او
الدوليه تونس تغرق في كل الملفات وتزداد
غرقا وانصاره ومطبليه وما زالوا في حاله
نقران وحاله ضياع ذهني كبير
بهذا الاسم
الخساره لمقاطعتك شكرا جزيلا لك الاستاذ
جوهر اللي بنبارك القيادي في جبهه الاخلاص
الوطني وشكرا ايضا لضيفنا منسوسه قيصر
الصياح المحامي والباحث في القانون شكرا
لكما لكم من اطيب المنى والسلام عليكم
ورحمه الله
[موسيقى]